pave one I'ma be sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen today we're back for another
round on metabolism Mythbusters because
we all want to eat like our twelve year
old self well if you missed part one
you've got to check it out here we
covered some of the biggest metabolism
boosters let's just say they weren't as
magical as we'd hoped so I'm back
hatchet with another couple to look at
let's get started getting enough protein
to flames while adding protein to your
diet will not add muscle gotta work for
that honey protein is essential for
maintaining muscle mass and muscle is
more metabolically active than fat you
want to make sure that you're eating
enough protein to support your activity
needs so ideally around 1.6 to 2.2 grams
of protein per kilogram of body weight
or some around 25 to 30 grams at every
meal if your weight training and you're
trying to lose that fat Chili Peppers
one flame capsaicin is the compound that
makes Chili Peppers really spicy and it
has been said it has the metabolism
boosting benefits now while the research
is still really young a small study did
find that even just over a gram of Red
Hot Chili Peppers had a very small
metabolism boosting and fat burning
benefit having said that you know the
research is really young we need bigger
larger studies and the impact is
relatively small so if you like heat go
ahead load it up with those Chili
Peppers but don't go using them on your
poutine thinking that that he is gonna
cancel it all the calories
high-intensity interval training to
flames high-intensity interval training
needs manipulating your heart rate in
integral settings like sprinting for
about 20 seconds and then jogging for 10
seconds compared to low or moderate
intensity slow steady training
high-intensity interval training tends
to show greater fat loss and a boost in
metabolism after the exercise session so
that means you can actually spend fewer
minutes in the gym for a better body
outcome sounds like a win-win to me
drinking cold water
rotten flame the theory here is that
cold water takes energy to warm up and
act that sexually energy burns calories
and while a small study did find that
there was a slight metabolic boost from
drinking cold water the office concluded
that honestly this would just burn a few
extra calories a day
so in other words folks water is super
important hot or cold and you don't want
to skimp out on that but don't go
thinking that having a cup of ice-cold
water is gonna cancel out that box of
powdered yonus you just polished off
whoops so there you have it folks no
magic pill yet together but stay tuned
because I got another round on the
tablets and Mythbusters coming your way
thank you so much for watching be sure
to subscribe to my channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen